cada día en brasil 15 personas mueren
por desnutrición escenas como estas son
cada vez más frecuentes unos 19 millones
de brasileños pasan hambre en un país
que paradójicamente es el segundo mayor
exportador de alimentos del mundo
superado sólo por los eeuu
la situación es especialmente grave en
las favelas donde el 70% de los
habitantes no tiene suficiente dinero
para comprar comida
este es el cuartel general de la central
única de favelas acabamos
desde el inicio de la pandemia esta ong
ha distribuido más de 22 toneladas de
alimentos a casi 2 millones de familias
estos alimentos vienen de diferentes
lugares personas físicas que acompañan
el trabajo de la cfa y traen los
productos hasta aquí y de empresas
es un no parar las donaciones llegan en
cajas y hay que preparar las cestas una
por una sin la ayuda de los voluntarios
sería imposible vamos a colocar más
mesas aquí así podemos colocar allá otro
equipo la cvf actúa en 5.000 favelas de
todo brasil en los primeros meses de la
pandemia recibieron muchos alimentos
pero con el paso del tiempo las
donaciones fueron menguando
alan vive en una favela de río de
janeiro cada semana acude a la cuba para
recoger las canastas solidarias y el año
pasado venía muy más porque había más
donaciones en 2014 brasil consiguió
salir del mapa del hambre de la fao la
organización de la onu para la
alimentación y la agricultura gracias a
programas sociales como el bolsa familia
pero la recesión económica primero y la
pandemia después han provocado un
retroceso dentro de esta comunidad el
90% de los habitantes son precarios
ambulantes o repartidores son personas
que trabajan para ganar lo que comen
cada día debido a que la economía está
parada y que la pandemia está aumentando
también crece el hambre cada vez más
alan conocí a todo el mundo y sabe
cuáles son las familias más necesitadas
buenos dias marcia que está lista
marcia tiene 43 años está enferma de los
riñones la llegada de los libres supone
un alivio me ayuda porque no puedo
trabajar trabajaba como ambulante pero
ahora ya no puedo estoy haciendo
diálisis tres veces por semana mi pierna
está cansada
el coronavirus ha destruido 8 millones
de empleos es el caso de veras que lleva
más de un año sin trabajar
yo he vuelto a recoger leña para hacer
fuego el día en que no hay nada como
harina de yuca bebo un poco de agua para
llenar la barriga y listo
el 55 por ciento de los brasileños es
decir unos 117 millones de personas
pasan por una situación de inseguridad
alimentaria
alessandra es profesora está a punto de
acabar la universidad y si suelto de
becaria no le llega a fin de mes
vive con dos hermanas y un sobrino pero
ni con tres salarios consiguen driblar
la inflación compré un kilo de azúcar
y un kilo de arroz
café y un kilo de espaguetis la leche
que es esencial y una salsa precocinada
es lo básico para nuestra alimentación
la fruta y la carne bovina han
desaparecido de su mesa ahora se dedica
a cazar las ofertas en el supermercado
aquí en nuestra casa siempre hubo comida
en abundancia siempre nunca nos faltó
nada
y ahora contamos los céntimos para hacer
la compra
según la fundación getúlio vargas en el
último año el precio del arroz creció un
61 por ciento y el de los frijoles un 69
por ciento
con la suspensión del subsidio estatal
en diciembre el poder adquisitivo de
muchas familias se desplomó el gobierno
recuperó en abril este auxilio pero su
valor fue reducido a menos de la mitad
por causa de la crisis
las iglesias se han convertido para
muchos en el último refugio desde hace
35 años padre julio lancelot y honra el
compromiso que asumió con los más
desfavorecidos
todos los días sirve de 500 a 600
desayunos fruto de donaciones solidarias
este religioso destaca que el hambre en
brasil nunca desapareció pero en el
último año se ha recrudecido
este gobierno ha conocido tiene toda la
responsabilidad de la muerte del pueblo
la pandemia agravó la situación porque
aumentó el desempleo
a sus 73 años además de embarcar en un
nuevo proyecto
en esta panadería todos los
profesionales son personas que vivían en
la calle en situación de vulnerabilidad
aquí aprenden una profesión y recuperan
la dignidad nuestra producción diaria es
de dos mil a dos mil quinientos
panecillos y de 1500 pastelitos lo
hacemos de lunes a viernes salimos para
entregar desayunos con 1200 panecillos
el hambre tiene prisa y cada vez hay más
personas con el estómago vacío sin
políticas sociales robustas brasil corre
el riesgo de volver al mapa del hambre
de la fao